I turned my thoughts towards falsehood
species of it however much more
excusable than that of others as I shall
at least say one thing true when I tell
you that I lie and shall hope to escape
the general sense here by acknowledging
that I mean to speak not a word of truth
throughout know ye therefore that I am
going to write about what I never saw
myself nor experienced no so much as
heard from anybody else and what is more
of such things as neither are you no
never can be I give my readers warning
therefore not to believe me
once upon a time then I set sail from
The Pillars of Hercules and getting into
the western ocean set off with a
favorable wind the cause of my
peregrination was no more than a certain
impatience of mind and thirst after
novelty with the desire of knowing where
the sea ended and what kind of men
inhabited this several shores of it for
this purpose I laid in a large stock of
provisions and as much water as I
thought necessary taking along with me
fifty companions of the same mind as
myself I prepared with all a number of
arms with a skillful pilot when we hired
at considerable expense and made our
ship as tight as we could in case of a
long and dangerous voyage who sailed on
with a prosperous Gale for day in a
night but being still in sight of land
did not make any great way the next day
however at Sun rising the wind springing
up the waves ran high grew dark we could
not unfurl a sail we gave ourselves up
to the winds and waves and were tossed
about in a storm which raged with great
fury for threescore in nineteen days
on a sudden a most violent whirlwind
arose and carried the ship above 3,000
stadia lifting it up far above the water
from whence it did not let us down again
into the seas but kept us suspended in
mid-air in this manner we hung for seven
days and nights and on the eighth beheld
a large tract of land like an island
round shining and remarkably full of
light we got on shore and found on
examination that it was cultivated and
full of inhabitants though we could not
then see any of them as night came on
other islands appeared some large others
small and of a fiery color there was
also below these another land with seas
woods mountains and cities in it and
this we took to be our native country as
we were advancing forward we were seized
on a sudden by the hippo Gabby who also
it seems they were cooled by the
inhabitants of these hid probably our
men carried upon vultures which they
ride as we do horses these vultures have
each three heads and are immensely large
you may judge of their size when I tell
you that one of their feathers is bigger
than the mast of a ship the Hippogriff
'i have orders it seems to fly round the
kingdom and if they find any stranger to
bring him to the king they took us there
for and carried us before him
[Music]
and as soon as he saw us he guessed by
our garb what we were you are Grecians
said he are you not me told him we were
and how added he got ye hither through
the air
we told him everything that had happened
to us and he in return related to us his
own history and informed us that he was
also a man and that his name was
Endymion that he had been taken away
from our earth in his sleep and brought
to this place where he reigned as
sovereign that spot
he told us which now looked like a moon
to us was the earth he desired us with
all not to make ourselves uneasy for
that we should soon have everything we
wanted if I succeed
says he in the war which I am now
engaged in against the inhabitants of
the Sun you will be very happy here
we asked him what enemies he had and
what the quarrel was about Phaeton he
replied who is king of the Sun that is
inhabited as well as the moon
has been a war with us for some time
past the foundation of it was this
I had formerly an intention of sending
some of the poorest of my subjects to
establish a colony in Lucifer which was
uninhabited
but Phaeton now to have MV put a stop to
it by opposing me in the Midway with his
hippo my army seized we were overcome
and assisted our forces at that time
being unequal to theirs I have now
however resolved to renew the war and
fix my colony if you have a mind you
shall accompany us in the expedition
I will furnish you every one with a
royal vulture and other accoutrements we
shall set out tomorrow with all my heart
said I whenever you please we stayed
however and supped with him and rising
early the next day preceded with the
army when the spies gave us notice that
the enemy was approaching the army
consisted of a hundred thousand
besides the scouts and the engineers
together with the auxiliaries amongst
them were 80,000 hipa gippy and twenty
thousand who were mounted on the latch
and op Terry
these are very large birds whose
feathers are a kind of herb and whose
wings look like lettuces next to these
stood the sintra Bali and thus Garuda
Maquis
our allies from the north were three
thousand select occitane and five
thousand and nama Johnny the former take
their names from the fleas which they
ride upon every flea being as big as
twelve elephants the latter our foot
soldiers and are carried about in the
air without wings in this manner they
have large gowns hanging down to their
feet these they tuck up and spread in
the form of a sail and the wind drives
them about like so many boats in the
battle they generally wear targets it
was reported that 70,000 strata belani
from the stars over cappadocia was said
to be there together with 5000 hipa
Gorani these I did not see for they
didn't ever come
as you're not attempt therefore to
describe them have these however most
wonderful things were related such were
the forces of Endymion their arms were
all alike their helmets were made of
beans for they have beans they're of a
prodigious size and strength and their
scaly breastplates of lupines
sewed together for the skins of their
lupines are like a horn and impenetrable
their shields and swords the same as our
own the army ranged themselves in this
manner the right wing was formed by the
heebie jeebie with the king and round
him his chosen band to protect him
amongst which we were admitted on the
left with a Latino Terry
the auxilary is in the middle the foot
were in all about 60,000 Myriad's they
have spiders you must know in this
country in infinite numbers and have
pretty large dimensions each of them
being as big as one of the islands of
the Cyclopes these were ordered to cover
the air from the moon quite to the
morning star this being immediately done
in the field of battle prepared the
infantry was drawn up under the command
of Nick Tyrion the son of udin ax the
left wing of the enemy which was
commanded by Fayette on himself
consisted of the hippo Muir my seas
these are large birds and resemble our
aunts except in regards to size the
largest of them covering two acres these
fight with their horns and were in
number about 50,000 in the right wing
worthy era canopy is about five thousand
all archers and riding upon large gnats
to these succeeded the era choruses
light infantry but remarkably brave and
useful warriors for they threw out of
slings exceedingly large radishes which
whoever was struck by died immediately
and most horrid stench extolling from
the wound behind these stood ten
thousand caldo my city's heavy armed
soldiers who fight hand-to-hand
so-called because they use shields made
of
shrooms and Spears of the stalks of
asparagus near them were placed the
cinebulle Ani about 5000 who were sent
by the inhabitants of Sirius these were
men with dogs heads and mounted upon
Wingard acorns some of their forces did
not arrive in time amongst whom there
were to have been some slingers from the
Milky Way together with an F Allah
Centauri they indeed came when the first
battle was over and I wish they had
never come at all
the slingers did not appear at all which
they say so enraged Phaeton they set
their city on fire thus prepared the
enemy began the attack the signal being
given and the acid spraying on each side
for such of the trumpet ears they make
use of on these occasions the left wing
of the healy 'it's unable to sustain the
onset of our hippocampi soon gave way
and we pursued them with great slaughter
their right wing however overcame our
left the air accompanies falling upon us
with astonishing force and advancing
even to our infantry by their assistance
we recovered and now they began to
retreat when they found the left wing
had been beaten the defeat then becoming
general many of them were taken
prisoners and many slain the blood
flowed in such abundance that the clouds
were tinged with it and looked red just
as they appear to us at sunset from
thence it distilled through upon the
earth some such thing I suppose happened
formerly amongst the gods which made
Homer believe the Jo rained blood that
the death of Sarpedon when we returned
from our pursuit of the enemy we set up
two trophies one on account of the
infantry engagement in the spider's web
and another in the clouds for our battle
in the air thus prosperously everything
went on when our spies informed us that
the Nephilim centaurs
who should have been with Phaeton before
the battle were just arrived they made
indeed as they approached towards us a
most formidable appearance
being half twitted horses and half men
from the waist upwards almost as big as
the Rodian Colossus and the horses of
the size of a common ship of burden I've
not mentioned the number of them which
was really so great that it would appear
incredible they were commanded by
Sagittarius from the zodiac as soon as
they learned their friends had been
defeated they sent a message to Phaeton
to call him back whilst they put their
forces into order of battle and
immediately fell upon the sealer Knights
who were unprepared to resist them being
all employed in the division of the
spoil they soon put them to flight
pursuing the king quite to his own City
and slew the greatest part of his Birds
they then tore down the trophies ran
over all the field woven by the spiders
and seized me in two of my companions
fate on at length coming up they raised
other trophies for themselves as for us
we were carried that very day to the
palace of the Sun our hands bound behind
us by a cord of the spider's web
the conquerors determined not to proceed
to the city of the moon but when they
returned home resolved to build a wall
between them and the Sun that his rays
might not shine upon it
this wall was double and made of thick
clouds so that the moon was always
eclipsed and in perpetual darkness
Endymion sorely distressed at these
calamities sent an embassy humbly
beseeching them to pull down the wall
and not to leave him an utter darkness
promising to pay them tribute to assist
them with his forces and Nevermore to
rebel
he sent hostages with all ferritin
called to councils on the affair at the
first of which they were all inexorable
but at the second changed their opinion
the treaty at length was agreed to on
these conditions the hell yachts and
their allies on one part make the
following agreement with the sealer
Knights and their allies on the other
that the hell yachts shall demolish the
wall now erected between them that they
shall make no eruptions into the
territories of the moon and restore the
prisoners according to certain articles
of ransom to be stipulated concerning
them that the sealer nights shall permit
all the other stars to enjoy their
rights and privileges that they shall
never wage war with the hell yachts but
assist them whenever they shall be
invaded that the king of the sealer
nights shall pay to the king of the
Helios an annual tribute of 10,000 casks
of do for the insurance of which he
shall send 10,000 hostages that they
shall mutually send out a colony to the
Morningstar
in which whoever of either nation shall
think proper may become a member that
the treaty shall be inscribed on a
column of amber in the midst of the air
and on the borders of the two kingdoms
this treaty was sworn to on the part of
the helots by Pyrenees and Thor itis and
Flavius and on the part of the sea the
Knights by Nick tour and menorahs and
polylepis
such was the piece made between them the
wall was immediately pulled down and we
were set at Liberty when we returned to
the moon
how Companions met and embraced us
shedding tears of joy as did Endymion
also he entreated us to remain there or
to go along with the new colony this I
could by no means be persuaded to but
begged he let us down into the sea as he
found I could not be prevailed on to
stay after feasting us most nobly for
seven days he dismissed us I will now
tell you everything which I met within
the moon that was new and extraordinary
amongst them when a man grows old he
does not die but dissolves into smoke
and turns to air they all leave the same
food which is frogs roasted on the ashes
from a large fire of these they have
plenty which fly about in the air they
get together over the coals snuff up the
scent of them and this serves them for
victuals their drink is air squeezed
into a cup which produces a kind of do
he who is quite bold his esteem de
Beauty among them for they abominate
long hair whereas in the commets he has
looked upon as a perfection at least so
we heard from some strangers who were
speaking of them they have
notwithstanding small beards a little
above the knee no nails to their feet
and only one great toe they have honey
hair which is extremely sharp and when
they exercised themselves
wash their bodies with milk this mixed
with a little of their honey makes
excellent cheese their oil is extracted
from onions is very rich and smells like
aunt menthe their wines which are in
great abundance yield water and the
grape stones are like hail I imagine
indeed but whenever the wind shakes
their vines and bursts the grape then
comes down among us what we call hail
they make use of their belly which they
can open and shut as they please as a
kind of bag or or pouch to put anything
in if they want it has no liver or
intestines but is hairy and warm within
in so much that newborn children when
they are cold frequently creep into it
the garments of the rich amongst them
are made of glass but very soft the poor
have woven brass which they have here in
great abundance and by pouring a little
water over it so managers to card it
like wool I'm afraid to mention their
eyes lest from the incredibility of the
thing you should not believe me I must
however inform you that they have eyes
which they take in and
whenever they please so that they can
preserve them anywhere till occasion
serfs and then make use of them
many who have lost their own borrow from
others and there are several rich men
who keep a stock of eyes by them their
ears are made of the leaves of playing
trees except of those who spring as I
observe to you from acorns these alone
have wooden ones I saw likewise another
very extraordinary thing in the king's
palace which was a looking-glass
that is placed in a well not very deep
whoever goes down into the well here's
everything that is said upon the earth
and if he looks into the glass beholds
all the cities and nations of the world
as plain as if he were close to them I
myself saw several of my friends there
and my whole native country whether they
saw me also I will not pretend to affirm
he who does not believe these things
whenever he goes there will know that I
have said nothing but what is true
[Music]